>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Edward Widmer: Good afternoon
everyone, and welcome to LJ 119.
We're so happy to see
so many friends,
so many current Kluge fellows and
my predecessor, Carolyn Brown,
who joins us as a friend of
mine and also of our speaker.
And it was under her directorship
that Peng Guoxiang was
recruited to the Kluge Center.
And we're so happy to present
his lecture tonight as the result
of a lot of happy years of research
here and in many other places.
Tonight's introduction draws for
me on deep childhood anxieties,
because I grew up as the
child of two sinologists.
My mother is still teaching Chinese
literature at Wellesley College.
My father was a Chinese historian.
And my form of adolescent rebellion
was to refuse to speak Chinese.
And unfortunately, I cannot refuse
to speak Chinese in
this introduction.
Although, you may wish that I have.
I want to remind you that this
program is being recorded,
so when you ask your
questions afterwards,
if you could speak clearly.
We're so happy to welcome Peng
Guoxiang for many reasons.
He's been a wonderful colleague
here at the Kluge Center.
He's a very deep scholar
of Confucianism
and its many incarnations.
He's currently professor of Chinese
philosophy and intellectual history
and religion at Zhejiang University,
has taught also at Peking University
and has held many visiting
appointments at universities
around the world, including in
Singapore, in Germany, in Taiwan
and several visiting
fellowships at Harvard University
where he used the Yenching Library,
which was basically the
unpaid babysitting facility
where my parents dropped
off my brother and me,
just about every day of the 1970s.
If you read his recent
interview with Dan Turello
in the Kluge Center blog, you'll
see what a special scholar he is,
because he has gone so deep
into the Library's collection.
He's made a special home in
the Asian reading room here.
And we're all happy that
digitization has arrived,
and it facilitates our
research in so many ways.
But as he has proven, and as I
think we all know intuitively,
there's a lot more to the Library
of Congress than what is available
on the surface, the digital surface.
And while here, he discovered
that we have 41,000 books
that have not been, that
are early Chinese books
that have not been digitized.
And so, he has made rich use of
those collections and has added
to his already amazing
output as a scholar.
The CD I have is a couple of
years old, but it lists no fewer
than 70 articles that he has
printed, published over the years.
And he has written seven books, and
I'm sure there will be many more.
They include, let me
just say a few of them.
This Worldly Concern of the Wise,
a Political and Social Thought
of Mou Zongsan, The Unfolding of
Innate Knowledge of the Goodness,
Wang Ji and the Young Ming
Learning of the Mid-Late Ming,
Confucian Tradition Between Religion
and Humanism, Confucian Tradition
and Chinese Philosophy Retrospect
and Prospect in a New Century
and Interpretation and
Speculation of Confucian Philosophy.
So he has taken a very old topic,
Confucianism, and made it ever new.
And tonight, he will do that
once again with his lecture.
And I'm especially proud to
say that we have a sinologist,
a scholar of China who is holding
the Kluge chair in the countries
and cultures of the north.
We have never had that before,
never had a China specialist
in that particular position.
And even though the word
north implies a certain kind
of Eurocentrism, obviously,
China is north of the equator.
And we're very happy to expand
our horizon in that sense.
So please join me in welcoming
Peng Guoxiang, who will speak
on understanding Confucianism
as a religious tradition,
salient features and significance.
Thank you.
>> Peng Guoxiang: Thank you Ted.
Thank you for your introduction.
It's my great pleasure and honor
to be appointed as the Kluge chair
in countries and cultures
of the north.
And I would like to express my
gratitude to Professor [Inaudible].
Unfortunately, he cannot be here.
And Dr. Karen [inaudible], the
former director of the Kluge Center,
and Dr., of course, Dr.
Billington [phonetic]
and Dr. [Inaudible]
head of Asian Division.
Unfortunately, he's not here too.
Anyway, just one word.
My thanks to all of the people
who have been supporting me.
As a professor of Chinese
philosophy, international history
and religion and of
Confucianism, in particular,
I would like to introduce
Confucianism,
one of the great traditions
in the world to everyone here.
Confucianism is not
something exclusively Chinese.
It has been introduced to developed
and [inaudible] in Japan, Korea,
and Vietnam, and other
regions of East Asia.
And now, it is even accepted by
Western people as an integral part
of their spirituality
and value system.
Example is that two Christian
theologians of Boston University,
Rob Neville and John Bersome
[phonetic], who were the dean
and vice-dean of divinity
school, respectively.
And publicly claim that
they are Boston Confucians.
It's very [inaudible] But Chinese
tradition is no doubt the matrix
of Confucianism.
So what I'm going to say
about Confucianism is based
upon Chinese tradition.
Before we enter into that subject,
I need to clarify that religiousness
or spirituality is only one
perspective from which to look
at Confucianism as a tradition.
Confucianism cannot be
exclusively classified
into any single modern
discipline, philosophy,
religion or ethics and so on.
Let me give you a story.
In the 1930s, when asked if
Buddhism can be called a religion
or philosophy, to [foreign name],
a modern Chinese Buddhist master,
and he replied, Buddhism is
neither a religion nor a philosophy.
On the other hand, it is both
a religion and a philosophy.
And [foreign name]'s
answer seems paradoxical,
but the meaning is actually simple.
The classification system of modern
western scholarship is not adequate
for defining Buddhism.
Either religion or philosophy is
just one dimension of Buddhism.
The case of Confucianism
is the same.
Accordingly, when we look
at it from one perspective,
it does not mean there
are no other dimensions.
Simply put, although we,
although the talk here and now is
about Confucianism as a
religious or spiritual tradition,
other dimensions, philosophical,
ethical, historical, institutional
and so on, are also meaningful.
I actually have more or less
tackled these various aspects too
in my work.
And my talk includes three parts.
Firstly, I will explore
the question of whether
or not Confucianism can be
understood or can be defined
as a religious tradition.
And if so, in what sense this
understanding is meaningful.
Secondly, I will demonstrate
there has been a strong dialogical
dimension in the Confucian
tradition all along.
And this dialogicalness [phonetic]
should be understood as one
of the distinctive
features of Confucianism.
Finally, I would like to point
out there are three contributions
that Confucianism as a
dialogical tradition can make
to religious dialogue, a dialogue
of most civilization
in a global context.
These three contributions are
number one, a principle of dialogue
that [inaudible] harmony
without uniformity.
Number two, a religious
pluralism that refrains
from those absolutism
and relativism.
And number three, a theoretical
and practical resource
that entails multiple
religious participation
and multiple religious identities.
Confucianism has been taught in
departments of religious studies
at universities in
the US for many years.
Yet, for some people, it
is still controversial
to see Confucianism as a religion.
And the controversies even
the fears and are prolonged
in Chinese-speaking world.
I published a book called
Confucianism Between Religion
and Humanism by Peking
University Press in 2007.
And a revised version is going
to come out this year too.
And for me, I think I have
already made this issue clear.
Unfortunately, there are
still some, if not many,
ambiguous understandings
and debates.
So let me first offer
answers to the question
of whether Confucianism
is a religious tradition.
Whether or not Confucianism can be
called a religion depends primarily
upon what understanding
of religion we have.
No doubt, as religion as a modern
western term is written early
from the Abraham tradition,
as you know,
including Christianity
and Judaism and Islam.
Accordingly, a transcendental
personal god, institution of church
and a single scripture
become indispensable defining
characteristics of being a religion.
During the 20th century, however,
some Western scholars realized
that religion encompassed much more
than the traditional
Abrahamic model.
An increasing contact with
the East suggested to them
that religion need not be
monotheistic or even theistic
to serve as a civilization
in the same fashion
as Abrahamic tradition
served in the West.
Examples are Buddhism and
Hinduism in South Asia
and Confucianism and
Daoism in East Asia.
So those Western scholars
with global consciousness
revised the traditional definition
of religion and made
it more comprehensive.
Paul Tillich's ultimate concern,
John Hick's human responses
to the transcendent, and
Frederick Streng's means
of ultimate transformation
and so on, are all examples
of this kind of revision.
And the reason that Wilfred Cantwell
Smith tried to replace religion
by religiosity or religiousness
is exactly to stress
that religiosity is one
while various religions
in the world are just different
manifestations of this one.
Therefore, if we realize that
the call of a religion lies
in its religiousness,
religiosity of spirituality,
which intends to make
people have an ultimate
and creative transformation rather
than in its particular form,
such as those features that simply
belong to Abrahamic tradition.
Our understanding of religion
should be revised and enlarged.
If we know that Buddhism is
originally an atheism that strives
for personal liberation, and Daoism
has never accepted the separation
between this world and the world of
all kinds of spirits between body
and heart mind, and if we
cannot deny that both Buddhism
and Daoism are two kinds
of religion in the world,
we must embrace the idea
that Confucianism should be
considered as a religion.
Why? Because it has provided
a resource, both spiritual
and practical, for human beings to
become great persons, [inaudible]
and noble persons [inaudible]
and [inaudible] in Chinese
by [inaudible] and
strenuous self-cultivation.
Distinctively, a Confucian way
of ultimate transformation,
the achievement of becoming a
great person, a noble person,
and a sage through self-cultivation
does not mean a leap of faith
from humanity to divinity
in [inaudible].
Rather, it precisely links the
full and perfect realization
of our achievement
of humanity itself.
So Confucianists, together with
some other spiritual traditions
in the world, should be understood
as a religious tradition,
although it does not necessarily
have the features of monotheism,
nor is it necessarily institutional.
In addition to the
definition of religion,
there are still two
criteria of judgment
that make us consider Confucianism
as a religious tradition.
First, Confucianism has
already been accepted
by other religious traditions
as an indispensable counterpart
in the religious dialogue
around the world.
Internationally, for many scholars,
treating Confucianism is a spiritual
and religious tradition has been
an unquestioned starting point
for further relevant discussions.
A few books in the English-speaking
world on Confucianism
from the perspective of religious
studies have been published
since the 1970s.
Quite a few international
conferences on the dialogue
between Confucianism and
Christianity have been held
in Hong Kong, Boston, and Brooklyn.
And all these are exactly
reflections of this point.
Secondly, we usually
acknowledge that the insiders
of a tradition have priority in
defining their own traditions.
A consensus shared
by representatives
of contemporary Confucian
scholars is acknowledgement
of the religious dimension
of the Confucian tradition.
For example, [foreign name],
a noted Confucian philosopher
of 20th century China,
clearly articulated
that Confucianists should be
understood as religious tradition.
And he has once even claimed
that Confucianists
should be reestablished
as an institutional religion.
And the [inaudible] a
contemporary of [Foreign Name]
and another distinguished
Confucian philosopher,
delivered a lecture entitled
Confucianism as a religion, in 1959,
many years ago, which was
included as a chapter in his book,
Characteristics of
Chinese Philosophy.
A well-known manifesto of
contemporary Confucianism drafted
by these scholars [Foreign Name]
and jointly signed by [Foreign Name]
and [Foreign Name]
was published in 1958.
I think it particularly
stressed the religious nature
of Confucian tradition.
So when we carefully scrutinize
the history of Confucianism,
we should be aware
that the development
of the Confucian tradition is
actually a process of dialogue,
including those dialogue
with other traditions
and a dialogue among different
schools of ramifications
within the Confucian
tradition itself.
It is this dialogical
dimension of dialogicalness
that enables Confucianism to
be more and more enriched.
Here, let me take Confucianism in
the Chines and East Asia context
as an example of this
dialogical dimension.
When it emerged in the preaching
period, roughly the 6th century BCE,
Confucianism was only one of various
intellectual trends among the
so-called [inaudible] in Chinese.
Literally, many masters
and hundreds of schools.
But through dialogue with other
masters and schools, Confucianism,
which started locally, you
know, in [inaudible] Province,
eventually became the dominant value
system of Chinese civilization.
Furthermore, even the thought
of Confucius himself was shaped
and developed from his
dialogue with his students.
If we look both at the [inaudible],
which is without doubt
the authoritative record
of Confucius' thought, and at some
newly unearthed Confucian text he
scribed on some bamboo sticks found
in the 1990s, we can recognize
that almost all Confucius said
was in a dialogue with others,
including his students, friends,
acquaintances, passersby,
strangers, and even his rivals.
From the Han Dynasty to the
Ming and Qing Dynasties,
namely from the 7th century to
the 18th century, the development
of Confucianism was
particularly characterized
by a dialogue process inside China
after a long and productive dialogue
with Buddhism and Daoism.
Classical Confucianism
was transformed
into a new paradigm known
as neo-Confucianism,
N-E-O/Confucianism, which
have solved the many Buddhist
and Daoist ideas without
giving up its own identity.
Also, through invalid dialogue
with local civilizations,
various new Confucian traditions
with their own cultural
characteristics,
was shaped in Japan, Korea,
Vietnam and other East Asian regions
after Chinese Confucianism was
introduced into these areas.
In this period, it is
no exaggeration to say
that Confucianists, in
general, played an important
or evening leading role in the
whole of East Asian civilization.
If East Asian civilization
can be differentiated
from Western civilization,
West Asia civilization
and its Abrahamic religions and
from South Asia civilization
and its Hinduism and Buddhism,
the defining religious tradition
in East Asia civilization
is nothing but Confucianism.
Briefly, throughout the process in
which Confucianist was transformed
into assuming a leading role
of East Asia civilization
from simply Chinese,
a striking feature
of Confucianism [inaudible]
is dialogicalness.
From the late Qing
Dynasty until now,
Confucianist has emerged
into another period.
In this period, one of the
most important features
of new Confucianism is also
its dialogical dimension,
compared with the previous dialogue
among different branches inside the
Confucian tradition and
its dialogue with Buddhism,
Daoism, Christianity and Islam.
The dialogue of Confucianism
is with the whole
of the Western spiritual world is
omnidirectional and multilevel.
In contrast to traditional Confucian
scholars, modern Confucius,
I mean Confucius from the 20th
century until now, have to face
and understand the
complexity and diversity
of various traditions in the world.
In this sense, the burden is much
heavier than ancient Confucius.
For example, both [inaudible]
engaged in lifelong dialogue
with Western philosophical
tradition,
especially German idealism.
Their understanding of Western
philosophy not only goes far beyond
the teacher [foreign name], the
initiator of modern Confucianist,
but also surpasses
some Chinese scholars
who are specialized
in Western philosophy.
As for [foreign name], a
great Confucian historian
and Kluge prize winner in 2006, his
understanding of Western culture,
in general, and Western
history, in particular,
surpasses that of his teacher
[foreign name], a great master
of Chinese traditional learning
in the 20th century China.
Now, as we know, religious
dialogue can be further divided
into two types, interreligious
dialogue
and intrareligious dialogue.
The former refers to the
dialogue among different
religious traditions.
For example, the dialogue between
Confucianism and Christianity.
The dialogue between
Christianity and Buddhism.
Hinduism and Islam, and so on.
The latter refers to the dialogue
among different branches or schools
within one religious tradition.
For instance, the dialogue
among Baptists, Methodists
and Evangelicals in Christianity.
But whatever perspective we take,
it is pretty clear that the history
of Confucianism is a
dialogical process.
First, let us look at the
development of Confucianism
from the perspective of
intrareligious dialogue.
I already mentioned the dialogical
feature of Confucius thought.
After Confucius, Confucianists even
in preaching period was
already complicated.
Different branches
were always in a state
of dialogue and sometimes conflict.
Typically, two different
orientations initiated respectively
by [inaudible] were developed
into an enduring dialogue
by latter Confucians.
Although Confucianists in
the Han Dynasty, in general,
focused on commentary on the
classics, a different approaches
and their debates, especially
[foreign name] and [foreign name],
among others, were also reflections
of the dialogue within Confucianism.
As for neo-Confucianists, a
well-known debate occurred in 11/75
between [foreign name], probably
the most important Confucius scholar
after Confucius.
And [foreign name] another
brilliant Confucian scholar
and [inaudible] contemporary,
reflected two different approaches
to the Confucian learning
in new Confucian tradition,
and was not only polemic,
but also dialogical.
Furthermore, the leading,
the learning of the [foreign name]
School was particularly shaped,
not only through dialogue with the
learning of [foreign name] but also
through dialogue among many
brilliant students and followers
of [foreign name] basically
in 16th and 17th century.
And most works recording the thought
of almost all new Confucian
masters recount the discussions
and correspondence
with their students,
colleagues, friends, or even rivals.
This is an outstanding feature
that indicates the strong
dialogical dimension
of new Confucian tradition.
Secondly, from a perspective
of interreligious dialogue,
the dialogue between Confucianism,
Buddhism and Daoism reached a peak
in the late Ming Dynasty.
And new Confucianists
per se was the result
of this interreligious dialogue,
which lasted hundreds of years.
The so-called East Asian
consciousness was precisely shaped
by the dialogue of Chinese
Confucianism, with local cultures
in Japan, Korea, Vietnam and so on.
This has already been
mentioned previously.
Now I would like to add
a couple of examples
to highlight the fruitful products
resulting from the dialogue
between Confucianism and
Christianity and Islam in China.
And those great Confucian
Christians such as [foreign names],
who all lived in the
late Ming Dynasty,
namely the 16th and 17th century.
Or even the Confucianized
[inaudible] missionary [foreign
name], also of the late Ming
Dynasty, have already been studied.
Recently, the thought of [foreign
names], which represents some
of the most important achievements
of the dialogue between Confucianism
and Islam, also in the 16th and 17th
century have also received global
scholarly attention.
I do not need to particularly
stress this biological dimension
of Confucianism.
Some great Western minds have
already realized its point.
For instance, William de Bary, a 97
years old distinguished professor
of Columbia University, believes
that the dialogical imperative
has always been embodied
in the Confucian tradition,
as an integral part
of East Asian civilization.
Actually, when we look at
Chinese history, we should realize
that the Chinese people have
embraced almost every world
religious tradition.
Buddhism, Christianity, Judaism
and Islam, let along Confucianism
and Daoist and the various
indigenous popular religions.
It is precisely because of
this intrinsic dialogicalness
of Confucianism and the
arrival of globalization
that religious dialogue, as
I've been trying to argue,
must be a leading project
of the 21st century
Confucianism in a global context.
As a matter of fact, one
of the [inaudible] features
for the development of
contemporary Confucianists is moving
in this exact direction.
Now, with the wave of globalization,
religious dialogue has become one
of the most striking
issues in the world.
Globalization means not only
a process of homogenization
but also a process of heterogeneity.
The reason for the latter is
the differences among various
religious traditions.
Therefore, how to treat
those differences and try
to alleviate the clash
of civilization caused
by religious conflict
through dialogue instead
of confrontation has become an
urgent issue for the good life
of every people in the world.
Actually, an essential aspect
of the clash of civilization,
even in [inaudible] is
still more religious
than political, economic and so on.
In [inaudible] statement, there
can be no peace among the nations
without peace among the religions.
And no peace among the religions
without dialogue among the religious
has been validated by history
and become a consensus
among people of religion.
So in my view, according to
what is has done in history,
a dialogical Confucianist can
make at least three contributions,
both conceptually and practically
to a global religious dialogue.
The first is a principle of
dialogue [foreign word] in Chinese.
Which, from Confucius, means
harmony without uniformity.
Until now, most participants
offer religious dialogue
in the world already have
realized that the purpose
of dialogue should not and cannot be
to transform others'
beliefs into their own.
Otherwise, the result is monologue
rather than dialogue and [inaudible]
and unavoidably leading to conflict.
Dialogue should be a
process of mutual learning.
The minimum purpose
of dialogue should be
to deepen mutual understanding.
Although mutual understanding
does not necessarily mean a mutual
appreciation, it is a precondition
for minimizing the possibility
of the large-scale clash
of civilization caused
by religious conflict.
In the Confucian tradition,
the principle harmony
without uniformity advocated
by almost every Confucian
throughout history,
has always been respected
as a way of coexistence.
This principle means every
individual shares a stance
of togetherness and
integration, while his
or her individuality
is fully developed.
Obviously, this should
be a base principle
for global religious dialogue
at present and in the future.
Maybe the based state that
we can hope to achieve.
There are two extremes
about religious dialogue.
One is a particularism that
believes dialogue is fruitless,
and there cannot be
helpful communication
between different religions.
The other is a universalism that
believes dialogue is the [inaudible]
that can lead people with
different religious backgrounds
to a homogeneous state.
By contrast, the Confucian principle
of harmony without uniformity
which goes beyond excessive
pessimism
and optimism can provide a
reasonable and visible [inaudible]
for global religious dialogue.
The second contribution
is Confucian pluralism.
Now we know that the attitude
a religion takes toward other
religious tradition can
be pathologically divided
into three categories.
Exclusivism, inclusivism,
and pluralism.
An exclusivist denies the value
of other religious traditions
and acclaims as a monopoly
of religion truth.
An inclusivist concedes that
other religions can have truth,
but he or she will say the truth
other religions have is already
included in his or her own religion,
and this truth is not ultimate.
Only his or her religion can
reveal the ultimate truth.
Anonymous Christians is an
example of this standpoint.
The third one is the
religious pluralism.
It is now a very influential
trend which not only accepts
that other religions
can reveal truth
but also realizes the
particularity or limitation
of every religious tradition.
A [inaudible] to inclusivism,
this standpoint does not presuppose
the priority of a certain religion.
A religious pluralist believes that
every religion can provide a way
of ultimate transformation.
As John Hicks' metaphor suggested,
all religions in the
world should be considered
as a rainbow of humans' face.
They are different reflections
of the same light of divinity.
Of course, every religion cannot
be simply and absolutely clarified
into any one of these three types,
while every religion can
simultaneously include these three
attitudes toward other religions.
Because of its openminded
standpoint,
religious pluralism has
been increasingly accepted
by more and more liberal minds.
But, pluralism in general,
has to face the danger
of becoming a kind of a relativism.
Pluralism with an implication
of relativism apparently
can't accept every religion.
But actually denies there
can be a unified truth
of the argument in the cosmos.
It is not willing to or
cannot seriously consider
that different religions can treat
the unified truth of the ultimate
in different ways and stress
different aspects of the same truth.
It consequently undermines
the necessity
of dialogue among religions.
So the significance of
a Confucian pluralism is
that Confucianists throughout
its history has developed a
middle ground.
As a dialogical tradition, Confucian
religious pluralists advocates
that on the one hand,
every religious tradition
is a manifestation
of the way all a unified
truth of the ultimate,
while the absolute truth that every
religion claims is only a convenient
way [inaudible] in Buddhism
or relative absolute.
Not the absolute per se,
at the ultimate truth.
On the other hand, the
ultimate and the unified truth
of the ultimate should be
acknowledged, no matter whether
or not this ultimate reality
and truth can be clearly
uttered with one accord.
I've named this distinctive
feature of Confucian pluralism
as the [foreign language]
in Chinese,
a term from the new
Confucianism, which literally
and roughly means one
principle, many manifestations.
The third contribution a
Confucianist can make is a
conceptual and practical resource
of multiple religious participation
and multiple religious identity.
And multiple religious
participation means a believer
in a religion fully getting
involved in another religion
or other religions and eventually
becomes an inner participant rather
than an outer observer.
Accordingly, once one becomes
not only an inner participant
but also a believer in another
religion or other religions,
while not giving up his or
her original religious faith,
this person already has
multiple religious identities.
Both multiple religion participation
and multiple religious
identities were issues raised
by contemporary Western theologians
or scholars in religious studies
against a background of global
dialogue, global religious dialogue.
For a conventional believer
in Abrahamic tradition,
multiple religious
participation is a very difficult,
if not totally impossible.
And multiple religious
identities are basically, I think,
beyond this author
ability to imagine.
But religious dialogue in academia
or real religious dialogue motivated
by globalization, especially as
part of the wave of integration,
compel this issue to
become a focal awareness
of Western religious people.
Intriguingly, in China or East
Asia, there has been a long history
of multiple religious participation
and multiple religious identities.
In the dialogical history of
Confucianism, a rich experience
about multiple religious
participating
and multiple religious identities
has already been accumulated.
In other words, for the
Confucian tradition,
multiple religious participation
and the multiple religious
identities have already been
at preconditioned or starting
point for further consideration
of relevant questions instead
of a problem still needing
to be wrestled with.
For example, there were many
brilliant Confucians who went back
and forth with ease among
Confucianism, Buddhism and Daoism
in the late Ming Dynasty.
They, on the one hand, deeply
engaged in the spiritual growth
of both Buddhism and Daoism,
including frequently communicating
with Buddhists and
Daoists, establishing deep
and lasting friendships with them.
Making commentaries on publishing
Buddhist and Daoist classics.
And even practicing Buddhist
meditation and Daoist inner alchemy.
On the other, they still had
their strong Confucian commitment
and identity.
Or they still defined
themselves as Confucian rather
than Buddhists or Daoists.
And even now, many temples
established in different dynasties
in Chinese history still
offer sacrifices to Confucius.
Laozi, as you might know, the
founder of Daoism, and Buddha,
in one house at the same time.
And all this exactly reflections
of multiple religious participation
and multiple religious identities.
As Paul [inaudible] observed,
the life of the Chinese people
has always been with diversity
of religious experience and history,
and a positive attitude toward
this diversity has accordingly
been developed.
In this sense, we can
say that the ease
of multiple religious participation
and religious identity has
already acquired its answered,
both conceptual and practical
in a dialogical Confucian
tradition with a plural vision.
So I do believe that more
resources from Confucianism
if primarily transformed
can contribute
to the global religious dialogue
in an age of dialogue or death.
The story of the so-called Boston
Confucianism, which I mentioned
at the very beginning,
is very inspiring.
Both Robert Neville
and John Bersome,
who are sincere Christian
Methodist ministers and professors
of Christianity have claimed
that they are also Confucians
since they also espouse the
core values of Confucianism.
Robert Neville even published a book
exactly called Boston Confucianism,
Portable Tradition in
the Late-Modern World.
No doubt, the emergence of Boston
Confucianism is the newest example
of, I think it's the
newest example demonstrating
that multiple religious
participating
and multiple religious identities
have already been happening
between Confucianism and
Christianity in the US.
This case also indicates
that the leading project
of contemporary Confucianists
in a global context is
primarily the development
for the religious and
spiritual dialogue.
Last, but not least, I would
like to say, and I do believe
that the dialogicalness
and the contributive resources
discussed just now are not exclusive
to the Confucian tradition.
We can definitely find
similar virtues,
more or less the other religious
or spiritual traditions
in the world as well.
If this part of every tradition in
the world can be jointly advocated
and promoted, a good life for all
human beings based upon solidarity,
harmony and common good,
would be eventually realized.
And it's not an unreachable
idea anymore.
So let me stop here.
Thank you all.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.